[Music]
welcome to thoughtful Thursday this week
we're gonna be talking about the
differences between rent to rent and a
lease option agreement if you haven't
checked it out already Samuel is over in
New York in America and he's attempts to
become financially free and buy a house
within a week that's pretty exciting so
I'm joined by Dave so the reason that we
got Dave on the show is because he works
for us member of our team so he's a ramp
up to all the time and in the last two
weeks he's secured a lease oxygen and a
renter rep so quick talent show thank
you for having me really appreciate it
I'm no problem at so first of all how
would you describe what a rent to rent
is exactly what it doesn't in a lot of
people complicates it but basically
you're renting a property some real
estate a house of a landlord yeah and
you pay them a specific fixed fee and in
return you essentially rent it out to
clients
yes you professional client to business
people to to the corporate market to
people who want to come along for a
holiday time
that's essentially what it is really so
you obviously you work out your
occupancy rates from there see I always
thing to it to a degree yeah the term
rental rate is a little bit misleading
as a name because typically if you if
you're renting a house off a landlord
see what you're doing here yeah
typically you live in it yeah right and
you rent it off them to live it yeah
we've a rent to rent obviously you're
renting it off of them in order to rent
it out to other people somebody else
however you're not really renting it off
them because then that would make it
that that would be like subletting we're
also really what you're doing is you're
managing the profits that's essentially
what it is yeah
so it's managing in this case five years
for me so I get all the managerial
rights but I totally agree with what you
just said there so you're not really
something you've meant to really rent
yeah
Oh a lot of people because of that get
Confucius uh blessing I will just some
betting well no it would be if you did
read actually went to read yeah I've
been it with an ASC contract and then
you rented you that have been aggressive
loan yeah but it's kind of its kind of a
cross
do you know each other - yeah management
are you a nesting agency you know
somewhere the great thing about it is
you get the management of somebody
else's property so you've not got to put
like twenty five percent in for example
on the mortgage so you know could be a
two hundred fifty thousand pound house
for example yeah then all of a sudden
you've gone through the contracts and
then all of a sudden you're in charge of
that then you're managing it for five
years and like you say you've got a lot
of influx of different people coming in
yeah which is great because it's a
win-win situation they guaranteed fixed
rent rent it's very much like its
business isn't it yeah you're not really
property investing you were as a
business essentially that's right and a
lot of a lot of businesses now so for
example air B&B yeah
they don't own any houses no so they're
like kind of like a hotel for making all
this money that owned the house yeah
sugar you own any cars up there they're
just using other people's so their since
that's what we were doing you're just
become in the middle man you're marrying
to the manic marrying up someone's house
yeah with someone else that wants to
either you know it as a to know so let's
come back to how are you doing
but you're just being the middleman
means you don't have to own anything so
grab a problemo making a better money at
it which is kind of the way it's going a
lot of yeah it's really good it's been
such a tremendous year and things move
really quickly when you start getting
involved in investment property and
peace you know what are we March already
yeah and all of a sudden I'm looking at
two deals that I've completed on we're
looking at two more going through yeah
receptive to businesses ones with joint
ventures ones on my own my wife so yeah
things are great
so really please would you describe a
rent rent rent would you describe it as
a win-win
it definitely is a win-win yeah I mean
why is it a win for the why is it for
the owner of the house yeah there's a
lot of people say to me well if you're
all gonna make money out of it why don't
they just do that you know why why are
you profiting from their house so what
in your opinion why is it a win okay for
the for the land well
I think not everyone has the same
mindset right that's how humans operate
so certain landlords especially my
scenario they've really tired
they really are we hear this all the
time I'll just find a tired landlord but
there are so many people out there for
whatever reasons there's exponential
amount of reasons it could be family it
could be travel there's loads of stuff
going on in this case he's already a
property investor you don't strike me as
tired so no I'm not like what I mean is
that landlord's got a lot of energy and
that's why I think I've managed to
secure this deal yeah because they're
like hang on a minute this guy's got
bags and bags of energy he's on it he
wants to get involved he wants to help
me I'm in a position where actually I
need to step away from this property you
know the reasons I've just said I'm a
tired landlord so it works it's a
natural relationship innocent so
business-wise it's always going to work
I think yes I think it's always gonna
work for you is okay but the person
that's doing the deal the entrepreneur
whatever you want to call them in this
case yeah it's definitely weird because
you're not hard game how much we
download you know what it's about a
ground bad branch anything in flats and
you making how much a month on the rents
a trend we're looking at around about a
minimum of 950 PCM to run about one one
to five thousand bottom ah yeah
so I make my whole ground back in the
first month in the first month pretty
much yeah it's cool well so for you is
almost a win but from there putting used
to win as well because what if they
didn't have you what they would do they
just rented to someone else but with you
they're gonna have no voids yeah they've
got a long term contract yeah they're
not paying a management fee guarantee
grunt legal guaranteed rent they've got
you look after the basic maintenance
yeah so there's so many pros so I think
what rent arrange brilliant I love it
I've got a strategy
alright so moving on yeah some people
get these little confused lease options
totally different situation yeah in the
sense that I mean the one thing that
they have got in common is the tired
landlord so you can get a lease option
agreement on somebody who's in a
position again who doesn't really want
to continue managing the property
looking after the property you have to
be given it a facelift or a
refurbishment so in that sense actually
they're quite similar but where they're
different in terms of properties is that
now it's a lease option agreement so
I've got an option it's not an
obligation but it's an option to be able
to purchase that
after a five-year lease which is what
I've agreed on with the adoption
agreement yeah
so basically breaking that down it means
that I still manage the house for five
years and the end of it I've got an
option to buy I don't have to do yeah
which is why it's called the lease
option agreement so essentially it's
like having a meant to rent yeah part of
wrong you've got an option to buy in the
end correct yeah so that's a really good
way of but not to work out the two
differences between the two yes I get a
lot of people fighting me off and saying
what are the fundamental differences the
actual benefits are really really
similar a lot of people say it's harder
to get a lease option agreement not if
you again find some people that are
wanting to give their properties away
because that's hired and a lot of people
say to me it's impossible for someone
just to say I've got property having a
property but they're looking at it it's
just the wrong mindset yeah the mindset
they need is everybody who lives needs
to live somewhere so houses a tenner
penny they're all over the place we're
taking a Greenbelt all the time from
Dundas United Kingdom and all across the
world doing it so we're never sort of
houses as long as what I was reading
actually that they're they're thinking
of building fifteen new towns yeah in
the greenback kind of around and that's
what I'm saying just to add extra extra
house so terrific London 15 I mean you
know how many more people is that going
to occupy meaning haven't went out there
you go well so if there's 20,000 people
then there's gonna be more necessarily
quite a lot yeah but my point is it's
gonna be a lot of people managing a lot
of landlords there's gonna be a lot of
contractual agreements going through
back and forth who does not who gets
involved with that and what about the
longevity of that and that's why I think
the Renison rent situation obviously
being so popular at the moment and again
at lease option agreements and I tend to
look at them I'd never really look at
them as one's higher than the other
because again that's the wrong mindset
because if you start looking at oh I
want a deal and that's really hard and
this is a bit harder so I'm gonna go
that way then you pigeonhole your
mindset into specifically going to want
monster I see what I like about these
options well in many ways lease options
isn't nothing I just got your coffee so
sorry that's cool in many ways lease
options is either
strategy know many ways let's say let's
say your strategies were HMOs or service
accommodation or whatever but I buy
refurbish it but whatever your strategy
is you can apply a nice option to it if
you put yourself in the game if you're
aware of it so if you know when you're
going to look at houses if you ask the
right questions you know and you're not
going in there thinking oh I want a
lease option you're thinking I want to
buy this house as a highchair Manion but
you're aware of the option that you've
got in your mind to turn it into an
asset you know it can becoming very very
powerful and again even with like a
renter single strategy was rent to rent
you could turn a rent to rent into a
lease or never rent rent Honolulu sake
I think I'm Alastair as I stared at this
he got at least oxygen Wolverhampton you
did you agree as a rent to rent he just
said to the guy so what should plan with
this down the line there yeah and the
guy was like well after about five years
I'm probably planning on selling it yeah
and he was like ding dong you know
because he asked the right questions
yeah and if you go with the right
questions then your belt has been solve
a pain so market investing is about
solving someone's pain would yeah it
really is would you say anything yes
yeah business is about it isn't
someone's banker this if you if you are
always aware of the option of turning
whatever deal you've got into a lease
option you don't necessary have to go
chasing lease options
no it's just be aware know how it works
so the grid understands the rules
understand the pros it's like sales is
now it is yeah and you're you're
identifying the problem yeah and then
you're solving the problem you'll the
marrying a problem with the solution and
see your face once a effort absolutely I
couldn't agree more with that I think
it's so essential for people the amount
of phone calls that I have a week if I'm
gonna do three lease options this week
what I need to do mmm that's the wrong
way of looking out what you need to do
is you need to find three people in a
situation where you can add loads of
value add value ask them the scenario
dig down to the credentials the
specifics while you're even there in the
house why they even agreed to let you
into their front door in the first place
have a professional business
conversation with them tell them how
can help them in and in in return they
can help you yeah and that is perfect
business in property which is why
Alastair keeps finalists options the
reason is the reason is is because he is
it running a deal sourcing business yeah
so he's continually putting himself in
the gang yeah since the right
environment he he knows what he's
looking for being the right one he's
making offers and to viewers he's
meeting landlords meeting estate agents
yeah
and he's just asking the right questions
cops absorb it so biggest takeaways be
aware of it yeah get yourself educated
you know what you doing yeah and then
just get out there take some actually
put yourself in the right place at the
right time which will happen it's meant
everything's meant to be you there you
where you on there for a reason you're
watching this video for a people orders
if you're minute education
so yeah I would say that that kind of
sums it up all day I really appreciate
you come on cue so I hope you guys found
that useful thanks ever so much for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
make sure you tune in next Thursday for
another thoughtful Thursday take care
guys
[Music]